you've had something happened for you
which is I think in my opinion hitting a
new level there's a company that makes a
skateboard have you heard about this and
they made a skateboard out of you and
first of all and I have it right here
and it is incredibly sexy this is real
we didn't make this up
it's it's really something and it's an
honor they haven't bestowed on on many
people they told me they made it of me
you're rubbing yourself keep doing that
that's great tickling
Brianna and then they made one of me
yeah and you that is so cool it's it's
but you know what's strange I was
thinking yeah like it's great that they
did this but then what was their
rationale for why you would be on a
skateboard you don't I mean there were
really big fans of yours but yeah I mean
well the the the lad who brought it over
and when brought it to my attention and
said we made this of you you want one
and then I brought one to you and yeah
he said you know they how did he put it
now they can it's so wrong to say no go
ahead you just murdered a bunch of
animals they're gonna ride they're gonna
ride on me that's what it is
Yunos weird since their feet are on you
that's what I don't like I love you it's
feet on your belly I'm not having that
no enrages me not that I would do
anything to protect you very weak huh
but I think that is very cool it's is
that mind again by the way did you
really do that for me that's fantastic
I'm gonna ride that and be badly hurt
you